you know we've all bought into the slide
that's somehow beating yourself up and
tough love and being hard on yourself is
motivating wrong all the research shows
that it is demotivating if you're
somebody that's stuck if you're somebody
that has regrets beating yourself up is
making it worse you have to learn how to
cheer for yourself where you are because
if you're not you will never find the
motivation to change so they did this
study with kids where they broke kids
into three different groups okay so
group number one got the old fixed
mindset praise where it's like hey
you're super smart Rich the second group
got the fixed mindset praise which is
hey Rich you're really really working
hard the third group they got a simple
high five no words the group with the
simple high five outperformed the other
two group and then some a high five is
fulfilling your fundamental emotional
needs when you high-five somebody
including yourself you are affirming
that somebody exists you are saying I
see you and you're celebrating with them